You wanna make it happen?
Life is short, let's do this.
Your mantra of choice is this: I'll figure it out.
You will figure it out.
You need to strike this from your vocabulary:...
...I don't know what to do.
You'll figure it out.
Remember this: everything you have ever done in your entire life, in the history of humanity,...
...has brought you to this point.
The first kiss, a blank page, white space.
A beginner's mind is an open mind, and an open mind innovates.
Respect your fear.
It's part of the creative process and it keeps you alert.
What are you gonna give up to get where you wanna go?
Because you can't have it all.
Aim for passion.
Balance? It's a myth.
Tell us your dream.
When you declare it and share it, you're accountable and you're helpable.
Every masterpiece that's ever been done? It could've been better.
The universe is always expanding and that includes you.
You wanna make it happen?
Do what you say you're gonna do.
Keep it pointed to where you want it to go.
Every day, today, now, do a little more of what you really wanna be doing...
...and do a little less of what you don't want to do, until your ideal becomes what's real.
You can make it happen.